a man who survived a novel choke nerve
agent attack in the UK says he's been
kept in the dark on the country's
ongoing investigation about it charlie
Rowley put all his unanswered questions
then to the Russian ambassador to the UK
Alexander Yakov anko now mr. Rowley and
his partner dawn Sturgis fell ill you
may recall in the city of Amesbury in
June last year initially police
suspected a drug overdose but then
claimed the couple had been poisoned by
Nava chalk Sturgis passed away a week
later Charlie Rolie met with mr. Yakov
nkow in the Russian embassy in London
our TV show Sethi reports feeling so
many of his questions were left
unanswered by the UK government
Charlie Rolie has met with and reached
out to the Russian ambassador to London
now he's lost his partner and is
suffering from deteriorating health and
he's also been confused by UK media
speculation regarding the poisoning of
his partner and Sergei in Yulia scrapple
last year by what was said to be the
nerve agent Navi chalk meanwhile though
the Russian ambassador has been trying
to fill in some blanks literally 80% of
what I told them was quite a revelation
to Charlie and his brother it's
perfectly understandable they're
ordinary people reading British
newspapers could they know only what
they're offered by the press so it's
good to have an alternative point of
view and understand Russia's line of
reasoning charlie Rowley and his brother
had virtually no info on the questions
we directed at the British authorities
over the scrapple case they don't
understand why we're not allowed to meet
the script house I told them that there
was no mobile service connection with
the scruples three hours prior to the
poisoning we had no chance to examine
this nerve agent it was all news to
Charlie and his brother most of the
information they had they had read in
the newspapers and I got the impression
that both the family of Dawn Sturgis and
that a Charlie Rowley have not been
adequately informed as to what happened
to the pen Amesbury and what happened in
Salisbury before they never received any
official reports for many months now mr.
Rowley and Dawn's family received very
little information about the course of
the investigation so little that Dawn's
son sent a letter to the Russian
president
the family of the late dawn Sturgis ones
first and foremost to see the
investigations conclusions Russia wants
the same thing it's been a year now and
we still haven't seen any official
results what led Charlene his brother to
contact us is precisely the fact that
they haven't been able to receive
anything from the British authorities
another points mr. Rowley raised is that
he felt his reputation was affected by
UK press describing him as homeless when
he was simply a British citizen Oh
Charlie and his brother are very nice
people
the first thing they told me was that
the British press misrepresented them as
hobos this is not the case Charlie wants
me to get this message across to Russian
audiences the Russian ambassador on the
other hand says there's so much left
unanswered we have plenty of questions
regarding the cremation of miss Sturgis
because it destroyed all proof making it
impossible to examine the results of
those investigations that have been
carried out by the British authorities
everything the UK authorities have done
leads rechecking including how these
people were treated Moscow was accused
of and has repeatedly denied any
involvement in the events last year and
offered to cooperate with British
authorities many times something that
London has rejected now the UK
government has still made little to no
evidence public meanwhile though charlie
Rowley says he just wants to know more
details mr. Raleigh's case came just a
few months after the poisoning of the
Russian double agent circus crippled and
his daughter in the city of Salisbury
nearby a March 2018 both survived that
though mr. scrip has not been seen since
the UK has consistently blamed Moscow
for both incidents though no evidence
has been produced for its part Russia
denies any involvement and says the UK
failed to cooperate in any joint
investigations political analyst
Alessandra Bruno says the media is
failing to ask the tough questions
surrounding this case the British media
is for the market for the most part
completely going along with the official
narrative after all Crowley is just
another victim in the disinformation
that this case involves the British
prime minister we
in less than 24 hours from the poisoning
which was unclear they had all the
answers who did it what did it and there
was the we don't know what the police
investigation is this is this requires a
real police investigation the biggest
role in the whole affair to me that's
caused by the Belling cat website that
claims to use open source whatever that
is information techniques to find out
what's going on from Ukraine to the
screen paths talk to the way the media
is spinning this this weekend UK
newspaper The Mirror published an
article following mr. rollies meeting
with the Russian ambassador it alleges
that the novel chopped vixen confronted
the envoi with a question did you kill
my girlfriend and received only quote
Russian propaganda in response however
the Ambassador says that mr. Rowley came
only in search of missing information
and here Russia's line of reasoning TV
host and political commentator Steven
mult spoke says the headline raised some
questions though the thing here is we
have to rely on the newspaper and their
account there was a video posted along
with the story in the story of the of
the Daily Mirror and and so we could see
part of the post meeting interview or
press conference there wasn't many
members of the press there so we have to
take what they say as as the story
because nobody else even Sky News and
others who have written about this quote
that from that story it's not like they
all had reporters there so in the video
we see first the Ambassador then we see
Charlie rally and his brother and it's
limited it's only about two and a half
or three minutes and it does not have
what the headline says he said it does
not have what the some of the things
that the story says he said does that
mean that they're making it up does that
mean they just didn't post all of the
video why they wouldn't post the meet
you know that the meat and potatoes part
the the storyline I don't know but I
would have to feel that if they are
severely misrepresenting what what he
said to the ambassador
that we will hear from him saying wait a
minute I never said that so I guess time
will tell
you